कि नमस्कार जर्मन सीखे हिंदी में कि ने इस
एपिसोड में आपका स्वागत है पिछले एपिसोड
में हमने वन एग्जामिनेशन के लेस एंड वन और
रॉ वन टाइम देखिए आज हम परेशान कर लेंगे
तो चलो करते हैं शुरू तो अभी आप स्क्रीन
पर दिख रहा होगा कि मैं इस प्रश्न के कौन
से कौन से पार्ट होता है एकदम सिंपल पार्ट
होते हैं पहला जो पार्ट होता है उसमें
आपको आपके पार्टनर के साथ कुछ तो तय करना
होता है कि आपको इस पार्टी प्लानिंग करनी
है या आपको एक ट्रेवल करने एवं बाद में इन
डिटेल देखेंगे उसको 28मार्च सोते हैं उसके
बाद अपन छोटा सा प्रेजेंटेशन देना होता है
कोई बच्चों को मोबाइल फोन देना चाहिए कि
नहीं टाइपिंग छोटा सा प्रेजेंटेशन देना
होता है उसके लिए 40 मार होते हैं और वह
जो आपने प्रेजेंटेशन दिया उस पर आपका
पार्टनर एग्जामिनर क्वेश्चन पूछेगा उसको
आंसर देना और आपके पार्टनर के प्रेजेंटेशन
पर उसको फीडबैक देखिए उसको क्वेश्चन पूछना
यह थर्ड टाइम है उसको 16 मार्ग व
कि पाकिस्तान में आप का उपचार कैसे होते
प्रणव सेंटर्स हाउस प्रखर उसके लिए और
16mar टोटल आप देखोगे तो टोटल सोमवार होते
हैं अगले दिन 60% को पास है अगर डिटेल
जाने से पहले अगर आपको याद होगा इस लाइन
जैसे आप इस कि इस पॉइंट पर आपको चेक
करेंगे हम देखते हैं एक्सेप्टेड सेम है वह
पॉइंट्स पहला ऐड न्यू रूम अपने सारे
पॉइंट्स पर कवर किए क्या सारे पॉइंट्स पर
आप बोले हैं क्या यह फलों दूसरा है कौए रन
सी है पर पर जवाब पार्ट-1 करोगे तो इस
सपोर्ट इंटरेक्शन कि वह आप इंटरेक्शन कर
रहे हो यार अपना ही बोलते जा रहे हो क्या
उसका भी सुनकर हुसैन ट्रैक्शन कर रहे हो
यह और पार्ट-2 में जब प्रेजेंटेशन करोगे
तो अपना को है कि आप इसको एक स्लो है और
वोट्स टो रेंडर 1954 में देखा है कि आपकी
अवॉर्ड्स कैसी है वहीं ब्रिक्स है और आप
ग्रामर पीछे अ हैंडल करता हो या नहीं
दैट्स ओके तो यहां पर आपको और
किया जाएगा और इन्ही में 16 मार्च
अपने-अपने विचारों के लिए है यह प्रोयोग
कैसे आप उपचार करते हो उसके ठीक है तो यह
को यह अभी यह हम कैसे होती है हम देखते
हैं तो बेसिकली डिस्टेंस जनरल यह पार्क
मतलब क्या कि आप और आपका पार्टनर दोनों
मिलकर एक साथ एग्जामिनेशन देते हो इंडियन
वर्ष के इस अगर पार्टनर नहीं है तो आप
वर्ल्ड साइकिल एग्जामिनर ऐड से झपट ओके तो
इसमें क्या होता है कि आप और आपके पार्टनर
अंदर जाते हो फिर आपको क्वेश्चन में पर
दिया जाता है अलग-अलग बैठते हो और फिर
आपको दो टॉपिक बीज मतलब दो चीजें ही जाती
है पहला कि आपको एक साथ क्या प्लेन करना
है और दूसरा युवक को दो तीन जी जाति है
उन्मे से जो आपको इजी लगे वह आपको चूज
करनी है और उस पर आपको पॉइंट बनाने हैं वह
पॉइंट कैसे बनाना है मैं आपको बाद में
बताऊंगा ओके तो यह 15 मिनट का टाइम खत्म
हो जाता है तो आप दोनों जाते हो दोनों
हिस्सों में के सामने जाते हो फिर
एग्जामिनर बोलता है कि भाई मतलब है स्लीप
स्मैल फ्रॉम मैन कैसे हो नाम क्या है आपका
गांव
श्रवण सीख रहे हो कब से जर्मन शीघ्र टाइट
जस्ट और की बैटिंग के लिए इसको कोई मार्ग
नहीं होते हैं बट ऑलवेज बेटर 2b स्माइलिंग
थोड़ा हैप्पी उससे अच्छा इंप्रेशन हमेशा
जाता है ओके फिर बोलते हैं कि चलो शुरू
करते हैं प्लानिंग तो फिर आपको दोनों को
शुरू करना बताया कि मैं पहला जो टॉपिक
ताकि आपको देख रहे हो स्क्रीन पर तो इसमें
क्या है कि आप दोनों को आधुनिक इसी
स्पर्धा में भाग लिया था और अपने दो टिकट
जीते हैं कि बालों को जनेऊ और वहां पर
कैसे जाओगे कि बाबा उसके लिए आपको चार
पॉइंट है वह वक्त कब जाओगे कैसे जाओगे
कहां रहोगे क्या लेकर जाओगे यह चार पॉइंट
दिए तो आपको इस पॉइंट पर मिलकर कुछ
प्लानिंग करना है एकदम सिंपल है रेटिना एक
दूसरे से बात कर सकते हो और वे यहां कब
निकलते हैं सैटरडे को निकलते हैं क्या अरे
उस चैफ ऐविंद को निकलते तो यह होगा ओके तो
वे कहते हैं बस या ट्रेन से और ट्रेन बहुत
महंगा हो गया बस यही चाहते हैं ओके
है और फिर मेरे दादाजी रहते हैं वहां पर
उनके साथ हम रहे क्या तो आदमी वह बहुत दूर
होगा उससे अच्छा है क्या मैं होटल लेकर
रहते हैं और क्या लेकर जा सकते हैं ठंड
होगी हम फूल और लेकर जा सकते हैं कुछ कि
अब बात कर सकते हो आपको अगर चाहिए तो आप
एक दूसरे आपकी एक्स्ट्रा पॉइंट भी ऐड कर
सकते हो या फिर कि जैसे कि अगर वहां पर
देखने लायक कुछ चीज हम देखते हैं क्या और
फिर वहां का कुछ तो बहुत ही फेमस है हम वह
खाकर देखिए कैसे एक दूसरा पॉइंट आप भी ऐड
कर सकते हो एकदम सिंपल है टेप को नार्मल
प्लानिंग करना है तो इसके लिए आपको ना कुछ
ज्यादा रेडियोमीटर यूज करने की जरूरत है
या कुछ भी नहीं है फिर भी अगर आपको पॉसिबल
है तो आप कॉफी यूज कर सकते हो विवेक रॉय
करके बोल सकते हैं अगर क्वांटम क्लियर
नहीं है तो नॉर्मल खोल सकते हो कि वक्त
your स्मार्ट करने से आपका क्या अपनी
सलूशन ले सकते हैं वह जो भी बोले उसको यह
चैनेल टोटली डे तो वगैरह बोल सकते हैं
वहां या फिर उसके अगर पसंद नहीं है तो पता
नहीं यार अच्छा होगा कि ऐसे ही चर्चा में
है
इस वंश वर्ब्स सर ऐसे करके आप बोल सकते हो
मेरी सिंपल बड़ा किए हैं प्लानिंग है इस
इंपॉर्टेंट कि आप दोनों में डायलॉग हो आगे
अगर वह ज्यादा नहीं बोल रहा है तो उसको
थोड़ा बोलने को बल्कि तुम्हारे इस विषय
में क्या ओपिनियन है या फिर उसको बोलो अगर
बहुत ज्यादा बोल रहे हैं तो मैं उसको बोला
कि मैं थोड़ा सा इसमें थोड़ा सा बोलूं
क्या ऐसा पूछ सकते हो कि डोंट लाइक शेयर व
सूरसागर मैं कुछ बोलूं क्या उस बारे में
अगर वह कुछ बोल रहा है वगैरह कुछ सुनाई
नहीं दिया ठीक से तो डोंट वरी आप उसको पूछ
सकते कि मैं एक बार फिर से बोलोगे क्या
कांफिडेंट फील टर्न ऑफ एनिमल्स इन थे
रिपोर्ट्स सकते हो कि डोंट वरी जीवन उसका
सुनाइए दिया तो फिर गैस मत करो इस वेरी
सिंपल मेरी सिंपल टाइम है जस्ट इंटरेक्शन
करते जॉब्स
थे सेकंड टाइम जो है उसमें आपने देखा आपने
थीम चूज कर देगी तो वहां पर क्या होता है
देखो कोई भी थीम जो भी थीम हो उसकी
रिस्ट्रक्चर आपको नहीं दिया उसने उस राहबर
में भी हमने मानव लिखा था खैर यहां पर
हमको मालूम लिखना है पर यहां पर अपने
एसेसमेंट्स क्या है कि उन्होंने आप एक ऐसे
5 प्वाइंट दिए हुए हैं आलरेडी कोई भी टीम
वह पॉइंट तो हमेशा के लिए गए थे कौन से कि
वह टीम की है उस पर बोलो फिर तुम्हारा खुद
का एक्सपीरियंस किया है उस पर उस पर बोलो
फिर उसके बाद तुम्हारी कंट्री में तुम्हे
तुम जहां से आते हो वहां पर उसकी कंडीशन
क्या है वह तो फिर एडवांटेज डिसएडवांटेज
दो और उस हिसाब से कुमार ओपिनियन दो और
एंड में थैंक यू वगैरह बोलो एंड और तो चीन
कोई भी हुई हमेशा यह सेम ही रहने वाला ओके
तो फॉर एग्जामपल अभी देखो आपकी स्किन में
दिख रहा होगा टीम क्या है क्योंकि बच्चों
को मोबाइल फोन देना चाहिए कि नहीं आप उस
पर क्या हो सकते हो मैं हिंदी में बोलता
हूं कि मुझे तो ऐसा लगता है कि मैं बच्चों
को मोबाइल फोन देने कि अ की जरूरत नहीं है
जब मैं छोटा था तो हमारे टाइम तो मोबाइल
फोन ही नहीं आप
वॉइस में आया तो मोबाइल फोन मिले मेरी
बच्ची भी कभी करके मोबाइल फोन यूज करती है
पर इंडिया में आजकल तो लोग बहुत ज्यादा
यूज करते हैं ना सिर्फ खेलने के लिए पर
पढ़ाई के लिए भी यूज करते हैं मेरे हिसाब
से उसके बहुत सारे भी सलमान टिप्स है कि
वह बच्चों की आंखें खराब हो सकती है वह
दिनभर मोबाइल पर यह रहते हैं वह खेलते
नहीं और उसके कारण वह मतलब उनके हेल्थ
प्रॉब्लम हो सकती है ऐसा कुछ भी बोल सकते
हो कि तुझे पैसे यह कहा मुझे पता है कि
इक्का दुक्का एडवांटेज है वहीं मतलब उससे
आपको सीख सकते हो वह व्रत है कि समझ सड़क
पर ऐड ऐड डाल सकते हो कि वह आप एफिडेविट
मुझे बोलना है कि बच्चों को मोबाइल फोन
नहीं देना चाहिए क्योंकि वह आपके हेल्थ के
लिए अच्छा नहीं है सिंपल है राइट अगेन
इसको बनाना कैसे हैं तो आप डायरेक्ट बोल
सकते हो कि वह बा ऑडिटर में स्टाइलिश
बुद्धिमान और डिप्रेशन क्या बोल सकते हो
फिर कुछ कहीं-कहीं लोगों को आदत है कि भाई
क्या बोलने वाले और फिर से बोलो तुम्हें
सॉरी वेस्ट में
दामन दामन आंख दान और तुम शुरू किया मैं
खुद नहीं करता मैं डायरेक्ट बोलना शुरू
करता हूं और फिर डालना शुरू कर सकते हो कि
वह मेरे बचपन में क्या हुआ इन माइनर की
साइड से फ्राई करने की जरूरत नहीं है उसकी
तरफ हार्ट कंडीशन में क्या होता है कि आप
बोल सकते हो इस साइड से अगर आप पॉजिटिव तो
अगर आप इसे पिघला कर सकते हो उनको वहां पर
टूट करो उसके बाद में थोड़े से अगर अपना
स्टाइल बहुत तो एक दूसरे को सब्सक्राइब
करें लाइक और सब्सक्राइब कैसे बोल सकते
हैं इस हमले में था सब्सक्राइब कर सकते हो
सकते हैं
है क्योंकि सुपरहिट क्यों तरफ साइड में आप
बोल सकते हो कि वह आपने ध्यान दिया इसलिए
मैं थैंक यू इस भिड़ंत रमेश कुरियर ऑफ
एग्जाम कट एकदम सिंपल है ज्यादा कुछ अलग
करने की जरूरत
भी बोलते क्या हो और आपके हेयर के बोल
है अब हम जो टाइम फ्री होती है इसके साथ
ही जुड़ी होती है ऐश्वर्या यह प्रेजेंटेशन
दोगे वह जो आपका जो पार्टनर होगा वह
बोलेगा कैसे गया आप उसको कैसे लगा आपका
प्रेजेंटेशन और एक दूसरा सवाल पूछना आप
उसकी सवाल का ठीक से जवाब देना फिर
एग्जामिनर भी आप कोई सवाल पूछेगा उसका भी
शांति से आंसर देना फिर जब आपका पार्टनर
होगा उसका जब तक प्रेजेंटेशन होगा आपको
ठीक से सुनना फिर उसको बोलना कि वह तूने
बहुत अच्छा बोला और मुझे एक दूसरा सवाल है
यह डिफरेंस आप सौंठ मियां गुड के फल है इस
बनवा नोखा इन ए फ्रॉग ऐसे कि आप बोल सकते
हैं बट से कुछ बड़ी बात नहीं है तो यह है
आपकी थर्ड चाहिए और यह जब दोनों का हो
जाएगा तो एग्जामनर बोलेगा थैंक्यू अपने
बहुत अच्छे एग्जाम दी बाय दर्स ओं अभी हम
आते हैं टिप्स को ओके तो सबसे पहले
एग्जामिनेशन से पहले क्या कर सकते हो
ज्यादा ज्यादा बोल सकते हो रेट
कि मेरी टिप हमेशा है कि 5 मिनट 15 मिनट
हर रोज जर्मन बुलाकर आज वेट बहुत होते हैं
शुरूवात में आप खुद से बात कर सकें अभी
मैं को चाय पीनी है तो इस मिस्टर टेस्टिंग
करें कुछ सही बातें और जैसे-जैसे आगे जाओ
एग्जामिनेशन से एक दो महीने पहले में भी
आप एक पार्टनर ढूंढ सकते हो और उस पार्टनर
के साथ प्रैक्टिस कर सकते हो और मैंने
डिस्क्रिप्शन में कुछ ऑपिनियंस दिए हैं वह
पॉकेट थोड़े ओपनिंग स्टॉक सेलेक्ट कर सकते
हो तो आपको हेल्प होगा अजवाइन अगर आप
देखोगे क्या करना है आपको एकदम सिंपल
पार्टी के ड्राइवर पर प्लानिंग करनी है और
एकदम सिंपल थिंग अपडेट में लाइक की थीम पर
बोलना है अगर आपको ठीक से बोलना आता है तो
इससे गांव के लिए अलग कुछ करने की जरूरत
नहीं है कि आपको जो वह क्या बीमारी थी वह
आपने ऑलरेडी वेंस है उनके लिए की होगी इवन
थॉ आईटी मेटल टाइम है जो नोटिफिकेशन है वह
अपने सफेद रंग के लिए इससे ज्यादा किए
होंगे तो आपके लिए अलग कुछ नहीं करना तो
सिर्फ बोलने की प्रैक्टिस करिए
मैं अभी तो एग्जाम क्यों एग्जाम के वक्त
इंपोर्टेंट यह पहले 15 मिनट जो है ना वह
बहुत इंपोर्टेंट है जो आपको प्रिपरेशन के
लिए हैं कि उसमें आप शांति से समझ सकते हो
और पॉइंट्स बना सकते हो तो मेरा खुद का
मानना है कि मैं सबसे पहले शांति से क्या
करो पहला पॉइंट पहला यह ठीक से देख लो फिर
दूसरे थीम्स में कौन सी आपको इजी लगती हो
मैंने शांति से चूज कर लो और फिर उस पर
पॉइंट बना जनरली कहते हैं कि जो पहला है
उसमें 1 इंच मैं आपको प्लानिंग करनी है
दूसरे को रिएक्ट करना है तो ज्यादा आपके
हाथ में नहीं है तो 56 मिनिट्स पर नोटिस
बनाओ और ज्यादा टाइम 9 10 मिनट 20 जो आप
प्रेजेंटेशन करने उसके पॉइंट बनाने थे
अज्ञेय डिपेंड अपऑन यू मेरे लिए यह अच्छा
होता है अगर नोटिस कंपलीट सेंटेंस में
नहीं बनाने एक तो टाइम जाएगा और दूसरा यह
कि आपको वापिस देना होता है अगर आप पढ़
रहे हो यह पढ़ने की किताब नहीं है रेट तो
वहीं
अजय देवगन गोविंदा एग्जामिनर तो पुरे
सेंटेंस नहीं लिखना सिर्फ जो पॉइंट आपको
लिखना है कि वह मोबाइल ना स्टाइलर नीस
बुजुर्गों वन बाय फोर ट्रेलर कोलर मन उसका
आपको इसका मीनिंग समझ में आया तो बस यह
नोटिस अगर आप ठीक से रखोगे तो आपको आगे आ
आसानी के लिए फिर जब एग्जाम चालू होगी
जितना हो सके कहां में रहना स्माइलिंग
रहना पहले जो आपको प्लानिंग करनी होती है
जैसे मैंने बोला ट्राइड टो हैव मोर एंड
मोर ऑफ डायलॉग कि वह आपके पॉइंट बता उसके
पॉइंट पर ऐक्टर अपने पॉइंट पर अडिग नहीं
रहेगा कि उसको भी बोलने देना अगर उस
ज्यादा बोल रहा है तो पोलाइटली पर एक करना
कम बोल रहा है तो उसको बोला कि मैं 13 तक
तेरा क्या मांगना है इस बारे में ओके
इंपॉर्टेंट थिंग क्या है कि वह सारे
पॉइंट्स कवर करना 24 दिए हैं एक्स्ट्रा
करोगे आप अगर अपने अपने खुद के तो और भी
अच्छा है कि समझ में आयेंगे
कि अ गैर इंपोर्टेंट इन यहां पर है कि
डायलॉग होना अगर कुछ ठीक है समझ में नहीं
आया तो फिर से पूछना डोंट वरी ओके खजूर
नेक्स्ट टाइम है उसमें आपको क्या करना है
कि मैं आपको देर रुक रुक रुक 3 मिनट आपको
बोलना है तो ज्यादा फास्ट भी मत भूलिए
शांति से बोला जी के पास बोले तो गलती है
अभी होंगी अचानक बोलते-बोलते अटक गए कुछ
समझ में नहीं आ रहा है शांत हो जाओ फिर से
शुरू करो इट्स ओके मतलब जहां कर रुके थे
वहां पर पहुंच लो फिर से आप बोलना शुरु
करो वही से कोई टेंशन नहीं है दूसरी चीज
की लिमिट सिंपल देखो सिंपल करेक्टर बोलना
इस लोट बेटर दैन कंपलेक्स गलतियों के साथ
बोलना ऑलवेज नंबर है कि स्पेशली स्पेशल
मैं आपको फिर उसको कलेक्ट करने को टाइम
नहीं मिलता है इसलिए आप तक पॉइंट आप सामने
वाले को समझे यह इंपोर्टेंट है इसलिए बहुत
कंपलेक्स सेंटेंस मत बनाओ सिंपल रखो नया
कुछ वहां पर एग्जामिनेशन प्वाइंटर मैं
ट्राई मत करो जो
अपने मित्र करते हैं वैसे ही बोलते जाओ
सारे पॉइंट्स पर बोलना बीन वेरी
इंपॉर्टेंट के ऊपर सारे पॉइंट्स में बोल
कराओ अगर इंपॉर्टेंट देखिए पढ़ना नहीं यह
पढ़ने की एग्जाम नहीं है जब नोटिस लगे तब
नीचे दे तो अभी देखता विनर की तरह आपके
पार्टनर की तरफ देख के बोलो एंड गिव
एडवांटेज समझ गया है और थर्ड टाइम तो एकदम
सिंपल है कि भाई सामने वाले के
प्रेजेंटेशन हो तो आइए तुमने बहुत अच्छा
किया बोलो और फिर उसको बोलो कि बाबा मुझे
और एक क्वेश्चन है और उसने जब क्वेश्चन
पूछे एग्जाम है जब खुशी पूछेगा तो उसका
आंसर दो एकदम सिंपल है ऐड अगर आपको ठीक से
बोलना आता है तो परेशान के लिए आपको अलग
कुछ करने की जरूरत नहीं है वहां पर शांत
रहना इस वेरी गुड
कि मुझे आशा है कि आपको भी वन एग्जामिनेशन
का क्वार्टर ठीक से समझ आया होगा हम मिलते
हैं नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में धन्यवाद